NICHOLAS CRUISE.
WE HAVE THAT AND ALL THAT MORE
BREAKING NEWS AND TONIGHT'S
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT, THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DRAWS THE
LINE IN THE SAND WHEN IT COMES
TO LIBERAL STATES AIDING AND
ABETTING CRIMINALLY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT POSE A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS USED A NEWS CONFERENCE
TODAY TO OFFICIALLY ANNOUNCE
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
ASSUMING CALIFORNIA OVER THERE
SANCTUARY STATE POLICIES THAT
SHIELD THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
THAT COMMIT CRIMES, SESSIONS DID
NOT HOLD BACK.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> A REFUSAL TO APPREHEND AND
REPORT THOSE, ESPECIALLY THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT EFFECTIVELY
REJECTS ALL IMMIGRATION LAW.
IT'S A REJECTION OF LAW.
IT CREATES AN OPEN BORDER
SYSTEM.
THE ONLY WAY IT CAN BE
DESCRIBED.
OPEN BORDERS IS A RADICAL,
IRRATIONAL IDEA THAT CANNOT BE
ACCEPTED, CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU
MIGHT HEAR FROM OPEN BORDER
RADICALS COME OUT WE ARE NOT
ASKING CALIFORNIA, OAKLAND, OR
ANYONE ELSE TO ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVELY ENFORCE IMMIGRATION
LAW.
ALTHOUGH WE WOULD WELCOME THE
POSITIVE ASSISTANCE.
WE WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE THAT,
BUT I SAY THEY ARE NOT BACKING
DOWN, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
DETERRED AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
STOP ENFORCING THE LAW IN
ALABAMA OR CALIFORNIA EITHER.
>> Sean: PRESIDENT TRUMP, JEFF
SESSIONS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE SIMPLY STANDING
UP FOR THE RULE OF LAW.
THE RADICAL LEFT ARE PUTTING
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
BEFORE THE SAFETY OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
ALL THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO DO IS ENFORCE FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAWS THAT ARE
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
IT'S REALLY THAT SIMPLE.
WE HAVE LAW AND ORDER OR CHAOS.
LET'S SAY YOU DON'T LIKE THE
LAW, THEN CHANGE THEM.
ELECT PEOPLE THAT WILL CHANGE
THEM, BUT IF YOU BREAK THE LAWS,
ON THE BOOKS, YOU SHOULD SUFFER
THE CONSEQUENCES.
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIALS DON'T
HAVE TO HELP, THEY JUST NEED TO
STOP INTERFERING.
WITH THE CASE OF THE OAKLAND
MAYOR AIDING AND ABETTING
IMMIGRANTS, WILL HAVE MORE ON
THAT DISGRACING STORY AND A
SECOND.
WHAT'S DISTURBING THAT ALL OF
THIS IS OFFICIALS IN CALIFORNIA,
THEY ARE RISKING YOUR LIVES
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO PROTECT
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THEY ARE LITERALLY WILLING TO
ENDANGER AMERICANS BY HARBORING
PEOPLE THAT HAVE NO REASON TO BE
IN THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY
THINK IT WILL WIN THEM A COUPLE
OF EXTRA VOTES.
YOU HAVE LIBERAL POLITICIANS
LIKE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR, JERRY
BROWN, THEY KNOW THE FACTS AND
THE TRUTH AND THE RULE OF LAW
ARE NOT ON THEIR SIDE.
THAT'S WHY INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING
WHY HIS ESTATE IS SHIELDING
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
GOVERNOR BROWN ATTACKS FOX NEWS.
HE ACCUSES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF GOING TO WAR,
REALLY?
LET'S WATCH THIS.
>> THIS IS REALLY UNPRECEDENTED.
FOR THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO COME OUT TO
CALIFORNIA AND ACT MORE LIKE
FOX NEWS THEN A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER.
THIS IS A POLITICAL STUNT.
IT'S MORE LIKE FOX NEWS AND
WHAT'S GOING ON IN WASHINGTON
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT THE TRUTH,
IT'S NOT ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
STATE, IT'S ABOUT DIVIDING
AMERICA.
THIS IS BASICALLY GOING TO WAR
AGAINST THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE ENGINE OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
IT'S NOT WISE, IT'S NOT RIGHT,
AND WILL NOT STAND.
>> Sean: IT'S NOT RIGHT, BUT
WE DID INVITE GOVERNOR BROWN TO
COME ON THE SHOW TONIGHT, BUT
SHOCKINGLY, HE SAID NO.
GOVERNOR BROWN HAS NO FACTS TO
BACK UP THIS ARGUMENT, SO IT'S
NO SURPRISE THAT HE'S TOO
GUTLESS TO COME ON THE PROGRAM.
LIBERALS IN CALIFORNIA, YOU NEED
TO ANSWER ONE SIMPLE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION, HOW DOES AMERICA
BENEFIT FROM CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS STAYING IN THE
COUNTRY?
IF YOU DON'T SEE THIS IS A
DANGER THAT HIS POST TO EVERY
AMERICAN, I DON'T KNOW HOW I CAN
CONVINCE YOU.
WHAT'S THE UPSIDE?
WHAT IS THE REWARD?
WHY ARE YOU WILLING TO RISK
OTHER PEOPLE'S LIVES?
THESE ARE CRIMINAL ALIENS, WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT DACA.
THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND WAS TIPPING
OFF CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ABOUT THE I.C.E. RAIDS LATE LAST
MONTH.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED QUESTION
WORK AS A RESULT, THE ACTING
HEAD OF I.C.E. SAID 100 CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE ABLE TO
AVOID ARREST.
IS THAT WHEN AMERICANS REALLY
WANT ELECTED OFFICIALS TO DO?
TO PROTECT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
AND CRIMINALS?
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS BLASTED THE OAKLAND
MAYOR EARLIER TODAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> HERE'S MY MESSAGE TO AMIR
SCHAAF.
HOW DARE YOU.
HOW DARE YOU NEEDLESSLY ENDANGER
THE LIVES OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO PROMOTE A RADICAL
OPEN BORDER AGENDA.
>> Sean: WHAT THIS MIRROR IS
DOING IS DISGRACEFUL.
DESPITE THE MAYOR'S ACTIONS,
I.C.E. WAS ABLE TO DETAIN
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
LOOK AT THE STATS ABOUT THE
OAKLAND AREA RAID.
232 PEOPLE ARRESTED FOR
VIOLATING FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
LAWS.
OF THE 2:30 TWO ARRESTED COME
OUT 180 WERE EITHER CONVICTED
CRIMINALS, HAD BEEN ISSUED THE
FINAL ORDER OF REMOVAL, AND
DIDN'T LEAVE, OR HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY DEPORTED AND RETURNED
AGAIN TO THE U.S. ILLEGALLY
BECAUSE WE HAVE OPEN BORDERS.
115 OF THE 232 HAD PRIOR FELONY
CONVICTIONS FOR SEX ABUSE,
WEAPONS CHARGES OR ASSAULT,
THOSE OF THE TYPES OF PEOPLE
THAT THIS OAKLAND MAYOR IS
PROTECTING.
NOW OF COURSE, LIBBY SCHAAF'S
DEFIANT DEFENDING HER LAWLESS
BEHAVIOR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
LOOKING INTO A POSSIBLE OBJECT
OF JUSTICE CHARGE AGAINST HER
FOR WHAT SHE DID.
KEEP IN MIND, IF CALIFORNIA
LAWMAKERS WANT TO CONTINUE TO
OBSTRUCT, FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS FROM ACTUALLY DOING
THEIR JOB, THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
SHOULD FOLLOW THROUGH ON HIS
THREAT TO PULL I.C.E. AGENTS
FROM CALIFORNIA.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS.
>> WE ARE GETTING NO HELP FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FRANKLY, IF I WANTED TO PULL OUR
PEOPLE FROM CALIFORNIA, YOU
WOULD HAVE A CRIME NEST LIKE
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN.
ALL HE WOULD HAVE TO DO IS SAY
I.C.E. AND BORDER PATROL, LEAVE
CALIFORNIA ALONE.
YOU WOULD SEE CRIME LIKE
NOBODY'S EVER SEEN CRIME IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE GET NO HELP FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
>> Sean: WHEN IT COMES TO
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, THE
MEDIA, THE LEFT, LIBERALS, THEY
REFUSE TO LOOK AT FACTS AND
BECAUSE OF THIS, THEY ARE
COMPLICIT IN THE HARM THAT THESE
PEOPLE BECAUSE TWO AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
UNLIKE THE LEFT AND MOST MEMBERS
OF THE MEDIA, WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN DOWN IN THE BORDER HUNDREDS
OF TIMES.
WE HAVE WATCHED FIRST HAND
WHAT'S GOING ON DOWN THERE.
I'VE BEEN ON HORSEBACK,
HELICOPTERS, BOATS, I'VE SEEN
WAREHOUSES, TUNNELS, I'VE SEEN
IT ALL.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS WE NEED
A WALL, HE'S RIGHT.
IN 2014, I SAT IN ON A BORDER
BRIEFING WITH RICK PERRY.
LISTEN CLOSELY, 642,000 CRIMINAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE STATE OF TEXAS
ALONE IN ONLY A SEVEN YEAR
PERIOD.
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WATCH.
>> CRIMINALS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ABOUT 642,000 CRIMINAL DEFENSES.
YOU LOOK AT THE TOP LEFT,
SEXUAL ASSAULT, THERE IS CLOSE
TWOVICTIMS.
>> THAT'S THE COST OF NOT
SECURING THE BORDER.
>> Sean: 642,000 CRIMES
CREATED AND IMPACTING THE
CITIZENS OF TEXAS AND A SEVEN
YEAR PERIOD.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA ALWAYS
CONVENIENTLY IGNORES THIS, TRUTH
DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER TO THEM.
ACCORDING TO THE MIGRATION
POLICY INSTITUTE, ABOUT 820,000
OF THE 11 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN AMERICA ARE
CONVICTED CRIMINALS.
820,000.
THE U.S. CENSUS COMMISSION HAS
FOUND THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ACCOUNT FOR 15% FOR THE
FISCAL YEAR 2016.
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ONLY MAKE UP
3.5% OF THE POPULATION.
3.5, 13%, AND THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THAT NUMBER IS ONLY DEALING WITH
FEDERAL CENSUSES.
MUCH HIGHER IF YOU FACTOR IN
CONVICTIONS BY STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST REPORT,
AN ESTIMATED 55,000 CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMAGE ALIENS WERE PRESET
ILLEGAL IMAGE ALIENS WERE PRESEI
ILLEGAL IMAGE ALIENS WERE PRESEN
THE YEAR 2010.
IN 2017, I.C.E. DEPORTED 226,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND ALSO IN
2017, OVER 127,000 OF THOSE
SUPPORTED WERE PREVIOUSLY
CONVICTED OF A CRIME.
IN 2010, THE DOJ FOUND THAT 57%
OF IMMIGRATION OFFENDERS CHARGED
THE U.S. DISTRICT COURT AND HAD
PRIOR FELONY CONVICTIONS.
THE FACTS ARE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE IRREFUTABLE AND THAT'S WHY
THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA NEVER
TALK ABOUT THEM.
YOU NEVER SEEN THIS BEFORE I'M
GUESSING.
THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING YOU,
THE AMERICA PEOPLE.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
WE HAVE MORE ON THIS IN A
MINUTE.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, WE HAVE
MORE EVIDENCE, MORE PROOF THAT
THE FBI LIED TO THE FISA COURT
JUDGE TO GET A WARRANT TO SPY ON
A MEMBER OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
ACCORDING TO A NEW YORKER
REPORT, FORMER BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WHO PUT
TOGETHER THIS PHONY DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES AND
PROPAGANDA KNEW, HE KNEW HE WAS
BEING PAID BY HILLARY CLINTON.
HE KNEW HE WAS BEING PAID BY THE
DNC JUST MONTHS BEFORE HE WAS
HIRED BY FUSION GPS.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO CONGRESSMAN ADAM
SHIPS MEMO WHICH REFERENCES THE
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARREN,
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENT
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENE
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENY
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENT
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENL
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARREND
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENT
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENE
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENJ
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARREND
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENE
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENT
FISA APPLICATION FOR THE WARRENA
STEEL WAS NEVER TOLD ABOUT THE
POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS BEHIND
HIS WORK.
ALSO REMEMBER, HE HATES
DONALD TRUMP ALSO.
THE FBI AGAIN FLAT OUT LIED AND
WHAT WE CAN ONLY ASSUME IS THAT
IT WAS AN EFFORT TO MAKE THE
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERE
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERL
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERI
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERG
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERT
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WER
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERE
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERA
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERL
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERJ
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERD
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WERE
STEEL MORE CREDIBLE AS THEY WER.
THEY NEVER BOTHERED TO VERIFY,
CORROBORATE THE FAKE NEWS
DOSSIER WHICH IS MANDATED IN
FISA LAW.
IT'S PART OF THE FBI'S OWN
PROTOCOLS.
ALSO, THE FISA APPLICATION WAS
DENIED THE FIRST TIME.
THE DOSSIER WAS BROUGHT IN TO
PUT THE REQUEST OVER THE TOP.
OR TO QUOTE ANDREW McCABE, HE
TESTIFIED, WITHOUT THE DOSSIER,
THERE WOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN A
FISA WARRANT APPLICATION.
THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT THAT
DOSSIER WAS TO GETTING THE
APPROVAL OF THE FISA COURT.
THIS SCANDAL IS BY FAR THE MOST
MASSIVE, DOMESTIC ABUSE OF
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT POWER IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL NEEDS TO BE APPOINTED,
LIKE YESTERDAY ON THE MONTH
BEFORE TO INVESTIGATE WHAT A
SEVERE ABUSE FISA IS.
ALSO TONIGHT, HOW THE FBI MISSED
A CRITICAL WARNING SIGN FROM A
DERANGED HIGH SCHOOL SHOOTER,
NICHOLAS CRUISE.
NOT A CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY, BOB
GOODLATTE, THEY ISSUED A PRESS
RELEASE ON KEY FINDINGS FROM AN
FBI FINDING ON THE PARK WHEN
SHOOTING.
IT'S PREVIOUSLY BEEN REPORTED
THAT IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR, A
FRIEND OF THE FAMILY CALLED THE
FBI TIP LINE TO REPORT HIS
DISTURBING BEHAVIOR.
WE HAVE NO INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THAT FBI AGENT WHO ANSWER THE
CALL HANDLE IT AND ACCORDING TO
GAUDI AND GOODLATTE'S PRESS
RELEASE, AFTER THAT CALL
WARNING OF CRUZ, A SUPERVISOR
WAS SPOKEN TO.
THEIR CONVERSATION WAS NEVER
DOCUMENTED.
CRUZ COULD BE CONNECTED TO A
SEPARATE CALL TO THE FBI TIP
LINE AND THAT'S WHERE CRUZ MADE
A THREATENING YOUTUBE COMMENT
ABOUT WANTING TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL SHOOTER.
DESPITE THAT INFORMATION, THE
FBI NEVER PROCEEDED AHEAD WITH
AN INVESTIGATION.
THE FBI NEVER TOLD LOCAL
AUTHORITIES, THEY NEVER TOLD THE
FIELD OFFICES ABOUT THIS AND AS
WE'VE BEEN SAYING, THIS ENTIRE
TRAGEDY, ALL OF IT COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED, BUT THERE WAS A
SERIES OF GIGANTIC BUREAUCRATIC
FAILURES.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO FIX THE
SYSTEM, CORRECT THOSE MISTAKES,
WE SHOULD SECURE THE SCHOOLS
LIKE WE SECURED THOSE HOLLYWOOD
ACTORS AND ACTRESSES WHO ARE ON
THE RED CARPET ON SUNDAY WELL
THE LEFT AND MEDIA PREDICTABLY
CONTINUE TO BLAME GUNS ALL IN AN